[Musique]
alors bonjour à toutes et à tous avant
tout j'aimerais remercier les étudiants
de polytechnique pour avoir pour m'avoir
invité aujourd'hui pour évoquer un sujet
essentiel qui est l'histoire de notre
pays et plus particulièrement celui de
notre patrimoine
alors l'algérie est justement ce vaste
territoire qui parfois été convoité
souvent accaparés ou trop longtemps
occupé notre terre fut d'abord numide
puis tour à tour phénicienne romaine
arabe ottomane et plus récemment
française avant que de n'être algérienne
notre culture est donc le fruit
d'importants brassage issus des
différentes civilisations qui se sont
succédé et nos visages garde un
témoignage en dés les bills de leur
passage peau noire blanche aux mathes
vieux des bennes ou encore boucles
blondes marque cette diversité des
genres et forment un ensemble de
communautés aux reflets jen algérie
plurielle mais que nous désirons
aujourd'hui une et indivisible
l'algérie a donc une histoire millénaire
et elle se révèle aujourd'hui sous un
nouveau jour
nous livrons ainsi les secrets d'un
patrimoine riche de ses multiples
influences nous permettant sans doute la
construction de notre identité est
assurément celle de notre futur
l'algérie est un territoire que l'on
qualifie de musée à ciel ouvert en
témoignent les cité antique romaine les
mausolées numide les vestiges de
comptoir phénicien les casbahs et
citadel arabe les porterai c'est pas les
ottomans ou encore l'habitat
d'architecturé haussmannienne si
certains de ces sites sont classés
d'autres malheureusement sont en péril
la disparition est même assurée pour les
sites non classé
la préservation et restauration notre
patrimoine est pourtant une condition
sinequanone à la sauvegarde de notre
identité sans conscience et connaissance
du passé
peut-on réellement envisager un avenir
l'édifice et le bâti prône pourtant
hanté direct d'un passées tantôt doux
l'heureux tantôt glorieux mais qui n'a
au moins nous appartient et sans lequel
on ne saurait avancer restaurer la
mémoire passe donc également par la
conservation de ce qui fut et qui n'est
plus c'est à dire
la transmission d'un art de vivre à
l'ancienne et le partage de ce que l'on
nomme aujourd'hui tradition us et
coutumes elles font partie intégrante
d'une société et révèle de l'ensemble de
valeur d'éléments matériels et
immatériels traduit et partager de façon
écrite ou orale est transmise de
génération en génération
leur existence tiens ou à leur
manifestation dans le temps spontanée et
répété il faut il faut adapter sa vision
à celle des anciens pour portes pour
bien comprendre leur époque restaurer la
mémoire demeure ainsi le moyen le plus
sûr de comprendre le sens
la richesse et l'intérêt de la
conservation de notre patrimoine pour
comprendre les différents aspects qui
composent notre identité multiple
nous ne pouvons faire l'impasse sur les
origines diverses qui ont influencé sur
notre premier outil de communication le
langage donc notre population est
majoritairement arabophones et si le
langage tamazight usité sous ses
différentes formes fut reconnue par la
constitution de 96 le parliez le par les
algériens diffèrent d'une région à une
autre
et s'il est affiliée à un idiome arabe
il demeure très différent de l'arabe
littéral l'algérien dont la base est
donc reconnu berbère fut enrichie par
les langues des groupes ayant influencé
cette région au cours de l'histoire
parmi elles on citera évidemment le turc
ottoman l'arabe andalou l'espagnol et
plus récemment le français dans sa forme
actuelle cet arabe algérien reflète donc
les différentes étapes qu'il a vécues au
cours de son histoire et la capacité
donc d'adaptation de cette langue
évoquons à titre d'exemple l'un des mots
d'usagé courant qui a traversé bien des
siècles et qui correspond aujourd'hui au
nom de notre monnaie le dinar
c'est un mot qui est issu de
dénomination arabe est dérivée
directement du latin des marius il faut
emprunter est désigné à l'origine une
pièce de monnaie romaine ou encore un
autre exemple de mots à usage courant
heureux là qui désigne un récipient avec
à orifices et 3 donc il serait issu du
terme
romain goulard qui désignait
l'orifice étroits ou alors encore le
gosier donc par ailleurs et de façon
moins surprenante
parmi les mots que nous utilisons il y
en a dont l'étymologie turc ne fait
aucun doute
avec à titre d'exemple le gâteau chez
avec donc sinon on a un autre exemple
qui est une onomatopée le mot youtube
qui a donné le nom à notre mouettes donc
toujours mal à en fait c'est simplement
le le cuicui c'est une onomatopée turc
qui qui à la base désigne l'oiseau dans
un langage enfantin il y a également
ceux qui se sont issues d'un mélange
d'arabes et de turcs comme par exemple
le mot et luigi legault or la racine est
arabe et loi et le suffixe ji est
ottoman nous utilisons encore
aujourd'hui d'autres mots d'origine
persane comme par exemple le mot choucha
dont la dénomination complète et shu
chez rôle m'a en fait ça désigne un
régime hat c'est pas si extravagant que
ça quand on sait que pour les orientaux
la chevelure épaisse est synonyme de
grâce et de beauté
or quand on sait qu'un régimes de dattes
est composé de plusieurs hameaux on peut
comprendre le l'affiliation à la
chevelure
il nous est pourtant difficile pour
certains mots de savoir s'ils ont été
introduits en algérie directement par
les turcs ou par les voyageurs et
pèlerins on sait simplement de façon
certaine qu'un certain nombre d'objets
d'origine persane tels que le tapis les
tapis les ustensiles en cuivre etc ont
été emportées d'orient par les pèlerins
une autre influence notable a laissé ses
traces dans notre langage les mots
d'origine arabe aux espagnols il y a
ceux qui ont été directement empruntées
à l'italien comme par exemple femmes
homos mais llull donc connu sous sa
forme francisé de mariole il est tiré il
fait sa première apparition en italie
sous la forme mariolo qui désignait à
l'origine escrocs ou rusé il aurait été
emprunté par les espagnols et transmis
aux algériens de l'ouest et il est
utilisé
puis le xvième siècle et fait les beaux
jours de la chanson raï aujourd'hui donc
d'autre mot espagnol d'origine italienne
furent introduits par les turcs porte
comme par exemple banques elles
provoquent pas en fait le lit à
baldaquin est issu de l'italien de
l'italien balde a causé la forme toscane
de la ville de bagdad
parce qu'elle pour voyez les autres
régions en tissu et en soirée
aujourd'hui une influence française est
notable car c'est l'occupation la plus
récente mais c'est vrai également dans
l'autre sens et si certains mots
français sont d'origine arabe du fait
des différences et ancestraux dont
d'autres ont directement été empreinte
nos langages algériens ou berbère ainsi
le movie est utilisé pour la première
fois au 14e siècle et tire son origine
du mot de beaux gaillards 30 sion en
berbère de jumeaux gates correspondant à
la village car la commune fournissez
jadis de grandes quantités de pin qui
remplaçait les suit dans les chandelles
le langage algérien est donc à l'image
de son histoire et demeure le reflet de
son parcours marqué par un important
brassage culturel le fait linguistique
algérien est souvent mis en avant par
ceux qui appellent au renouveau
identitaire
ceux ci revendique la spécificité de la
langue algérienne m met en avant sa
nécessaire préservation et sa
revendication en tant que la langue
nationale légitime
l'argument principal avancé pour
justifier la nécessaire préservation
étant la prise en compte du patrimoine
culturel constitué de poèmes de récits
et de chansons dépendant de cette langue
la pluralité de la langue et sa richesse
nous amène à évoquer l'importance de
l'oralité dans l'apprentissage
transmission et préservation des
traditions algériennes
car l'identité d'un peuple ne saurait se
résumer à la seule connaissance de son
histoire événementielle la
représentation des mythes fondateurs
contes et légendes traditions et
croyances populaires nous propulse au
cul rond au coeur même du mode de
fonctionnement d'une communauté
reconnu depuis l'antiquité en tant que
maîtresse de foyers du fait de la
position et de la place qu'elle occupe
autant au sein de l'as
ellul familiale les femmes sont
reconnues garante et dépositaire d'un
savoir séculaire et demeure de façon
indéniable un pilier majeur de la
transmission orale et donc de
l'apprentissage et de la préservation d
août ses coutumes à titre d'exemple nous
pouvons évoquer les pratiques de la
population kabyle qui a longtemps baigné
dans un univers peuplé de croyance
magico religieuse parmi les rituels
magiques les plus prisés on dénombre
ceux auxquels on a recours pour prendre
son destin en main
on appelle cela de la magie positif car
ils interviennent le plus souvent en cas
d'un fortune ou d'un destin qui se fait
attendre
il faut préciser que les communautés où
la structure familiale joue un rôle
prépondérant dans la bonne marche de la
société
les trois choses considérées comme
essentielles et qui rythme la vie après
la naissance sont le passage à l'âge
adulte
le mariage et la procréation si l'une
d'elles fait défaut la réputation de la
famille sans vieira ternie et les
relations sociales donc économique
altérée autant dire de façon avéré que
la place de la tradition et de la
transmission joue ici un rôle majeur
dans la bonne marche de la société
dans un tout autre registre nous avons
le jeu de boca là qui est à l'origine
une pratique divinatoire devenu un jeu
accompagné de courts poèmes résister ou
improvisée pour être à la fin
interprétées comme des présages le jeu
de bourrin là était très en vogue dans
les vieilles cités d'alger et ses
environs et la pratique est attestée dès
le xvième siècle ce jeu étaient
également pratiquées par des femmes
et aujourd'hui elle bocal à est
considéré comme un patrimoine que nous
devons préserver si sa pratique tombe en
effet en désuétude
quelques auteurs algériens s'attellent
désormais à la collecte de la
retranscription des innombrables bora
let dont certaines sont très
révélatrices dans l'art de
l'improvisation et de la versification
de nos aïeuls le rôle des récits des
contes et des légendes n'est plus à
démontrer et dans certaines régions
influence bédouine le russe le récif
longtemps diffusé par l goût elle
littéralement celui qui dit son rôle est
de relater les prouesses du héros arabo
musulman dans les endroits à large
diffusion les places publiques les lieux
de cours de culte pardon les marchés
hebdomadaires etc
la tradition du goût elle fut longtemps
ancré dans une réalité sociale et
politique car et les et l'incarnent
l'esprit qui veille sur la cohésion
tribales mais les récits que nous autres
citadins gardant en tête sont évidemment
ceux qui nous ont été rapportées par nos
mères et nos grands mères avant elle
nous retenons l'histoire ou plutôt la
légende la plus connue celle dite de
fatéma hal macra ou fatima la farde et
donc c'est une vieille légende d'alger
elle est porteuse d'un message et d'une
morale et l' influence de ce récit fut
tel que s'il vous arrive encore de vous
promener dans les ruelles de la casbah
vous pouvez demander votre chemin et
vous pouvez toujours visiter cette
maison
enfin les traditions algériennes encore
présente aujourd'hui son temps observer
à travers les cérémonies qui ponctuent
nos vies à savoir les naissances les
mariages et autres circoncision par
exemple le rituel des bains et du vin et
de la mise en beauté de la mariée forme
une coutume très féminine que l'on
s'oblige à suivre dans le détail à
l'origine chaque geste toutes pratiques
liées à cet événement est révélatrice
d'une croyance
ainsi le jour convenu du bain tout un
cortège de femmes à pied suivent la
fiancée en direction de jeu hammam
entièrement réservé par la famille pour
l'occasion la cérémonie ainsi que les
objets nécessaires robin tels que la
fameuse passe en cuivre le maire baisse
de benoît ou encore la fota font partie
intégrante de notre patrimoine
immatériel
il y a encore quelques temps il existait
même une profession purement féminine
dont la représentante était chargée de
veiller à la bonne marche des pratiques
rituelles et traditionnel lors de ces
cérémonies il s'agit bien évidemment je
métier de m'acheter extrêmement
appréciée pour son rôle d'esthéticienne
et son influence par ses connaissances
des us et coutumes ses conseils fort
avisée
on vous faisait très très souvent appel
à elle pour pour les cérémonies de
mariage classique donc mais est ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui que les femmes
malgré un regain d'intérêt et gray le
fait qu'on puisse refaire appel à la
machta ou qu'on fasse référence à
d'autres us et coutumes qui sont tombées
en désuétude
est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui que
la place dès que les femmes sont
toujours dépositaire et 40 de ce savoir
sachant qu'avec la vie moderne
elles font partie intégrante de la
société civile et ne peuvent plus
assumer ce rôle apparence à la part
entière alors aujourd'hui ça à l'école
d'assumer ce rôle mais pas uniquement
et évidemment c'est à la jeune nation de
se prévaloir de ce combat car la quête
pour l'identité est notre combat nous
devons donc nous devrons poursuivre
jusqu'au bout car s'en passer on peut
pas avoir d'avenir
merci pour votre équipe
[Musique]